so Matt is an actor where did you find
your voice for John Constantine my voice
will actually replace personality for
John Constantine of the comics I mean
yeah I started reading them I haven't
read them all the artists there's a lot
of them but uh the I've just started
reading them I'm using the source
material and then I've got this big
scheme just all my dog Constantine
studying images and just cleaning as
much as I can
it's funny I've been told for years and
years by a friend of mine who was a big
comic book fan he's got his own comic
book company now called improper books
and they got some good stuff and he'd
been telling me for years John
Constantine's my favorite you know comic
book character the Hellblazer stuff and
um and then when I when I got the
audition he was like sat me down man and
took me through the wringer he was just
like right okay he's gonna be like this
and so yeah he's he's like my worst
critic
you're my accents different yeah exactly
ya know a lot of people yeah a lot of
people being saying I'm using my own axe
and I'm not using my own axe and you
know the funny thing is Liverpool is
right next door to Wales it's like
literally you know but um you know the
thing is I thought about doing a full-on
Liverpudlian accent but you'd have to
put subtitles on it you would for a
full-on Welsh accent as well and so we
you know I kind of came came up with the
idea that you know he's from Liverpool
I'm from Wales but then I left I left
Wales when I was 19 and then I've
traveled so my accent isn't as thick as
it would be if I was still living in
Wales so I applied that to John it's
like he was he was born in Liverpool he
brought up that but then he moved away
so so we've taken the basis of our
accent and the vowel sounds and the
consonants and then just get out and
then some of the vowel sounds are
actually similar to to the Welsh Botox
because they're right next door to each
other anyway so it's kind of it's kind
of a more accessible kind of traveled
accent
it was it was quite tough man yeah I was
doing a play in London and and I was I
was doing a Shakespeare play Henry the
fifth in London I had long hair and a
big beard and when I did my first tier 4
they were just like yeah that Daniel and
David really liked me so I went through
this whole process have to wait for the
play to finish and then and then flew
over to LA chopper
so which of the character enjoyed
interacting with both songs great so far
I'd say mani mani because they've got
this grid that they both kind of
manipulators you know and they're both
kind of trying to get one up on each
other all the time but there's also a
mutual respect for each other so there's
this kind of dance this toe-to-toe dance
that they're doing all the time they're
they're uneasy allies you know and I
think that makes for a really
interesting dynamic and interesting kind
of conflict between the two
you